let's go next to patrick from vernon
hills patrick from vernon hills you're
on the air
hey david how's it going it's going well
uh
i guess i have a question about
can where we go forward with our media
ecosystem
i read a book recently that looked at
the
historical effects of networks in
society specific a good parallel was
when the printing press was created and
then christianity shattered into a
thousand pieces and
we had decades of war after that because
everybody could read their own
interpretation of the bible instead of
it all coming through the catholic
church
and it feels now like media has been
shattered
into a thousand pieces and we all just
get
wherever we want and you know talking to
conservatives they don't even they
haven't even read the same stories
they've read and we're
just operating from a completely
different set of information
and we can't even talk about ideas we're
just talking about
what's true and what's not true you know
i love that you're bringing this up i
love that you're bringing this up
because
um you know one of the things there was
a very interesting discussion on the
david pakman show subreddit recently
where someone posted
uh they did it in sort of an attack way
but i still appreciated it they said you
know
um listening to the david pakman show
watching the david pakman
show alone is not going to make you
informed or educated or smart or
whatever
and they meant it i think as an attack
but i don't see
i agree with that and one of the things
that i have been talking about for a
long time is
um my my hope with this show
is not that people end up believing all
the same things that i believe
and my hope is not that i become the
sole
source of commentary for people what i
hope to do with this show
is to be part of the commentary
diet and hopefully expose people to the
importance
of reading economics and reading history
and reading sociology and philosophy
and one of the real concerns with a lot
of this right-wing
drivel that's out there is the same
thing we heard from trump which was
only i can fix it only i tell you the
truth
you're not being told the truth here or
there and this is fake news and that's
fake news
and all of this stuff what you're
pointing out is maybe
i don't know if you're deliberately
pointing this out or not but i'm going
to pretend you are because it's such a
great point
it's really important for us to be
consuming
lots of writing that has sort of stood
the test of time
ideas and books that are still being
read
decades after they've been written
sometimes centuries after they've been
written you know really long time and
nasim nasim talib in the black swan
and anti fr antifragile writes about
this
you really want to be starting with your
base and that should be
you know really reading texts of his
history economics philosophy etc
then on top of that you place news
actual news reporting that's going on
and the top of the pyramid
pyramid should be shows like mine where
i'm not giving you
an opinion on an empty platform
hopefully you are coming in with the
base
of the pyramid and i'm just giving you
my thoughts and we all are sharing a lot
of this information now unfortunately as
you're pointing out a lot of people come
in and just listen to opinion shows
and don't know history economics
philosophy science etc that's a problem
but but you're
uh i'm i'm off on a rampage but you're
making a beautiful point
yeah i think that's um not quite what i
was getting at but pretty close
i like your hierarchy of knowledge that
you
um laid out there right i'm just in a a
rear
i'm just concerned that you know people
aren't
doing that and they are just really
getting their information from
the top of the pyramid they don't have
their face that's no no your your
assessment is correct that's what's
happening and it's horrible
i can't talk to people because i'm just
we we don't even have a common
set of facts to talk about and it's so
frustrating
talking about is this true or is this
not true i like
climate change i you know climate change
is real what do we do about it but
we're stuck on is climate change real
yeah the interesting question is
what do we do about it there's a lot of
good weight there's thousands of ways to
solve the problem
but like alcoholics anonymous you know
the first step is admitting you have a
problem you can't do anything until
you get past that first step absolutely
yeah i'm i'm reading a merchants of
doubt now about
the industry of denying that
tobacco smoke is harmful to health
denying that acid rain is bad denying
that there's climate change and uh
there's entire industries based around
furthering doubt about that and so it's
not
uh part of it is uneducated people but
also part of it is very well-funded
industries that want people to doubt
the facts yep
all right thank you so much i love your
show all right thank you great great
call appreciate it very very important
things being brought up